Alright. So we talked through how it works when you've got
you're trying to fit your data to a constant function,
to a zero order polynomial. But let's, let's at least talk
through how you do this in the more general case. This
is, this is what I've been doing to, to fit various
curves to the data at least implicitly. So, what we're
really trying to do is we've got a set of data,
x and y. Set n, n examples of x's and their
corresponding y's. And what we're trying to find is these coefficients,
C0, C1, C2, C3. Let's say if we're trying to do cubic regression
where C0 gets added to C1 times x, which gets added to C2 times
x squared. Which gets added to C3 times X cubed and we're trying to get
that to look a lot like y. Now we're not
going to get to exactly equal y but let's pretend for a
moment that we could. We have a bunch of these
examples and we want it to work for all of them.
So we can arrange all of the, all these
constraints, all these equations into matrix form. If you're familiar
with linear algebra. So the way that we can
write this is here are the, here are the coefficients
that we're looking for, the C's, and here are
what we're going to multiply them by. We're going to take
the X one and look at the zeroth power,
the second power, the third power. And that equation I'll
use my hands cause that's I always, I always
need to use my hands when I do matrix
multiplication. So you're going to across here and down there
to multiply these and add. And that needs to correspond
to y1. And same thing this now the second
row. Multiplied by these coefficients. Need to give us our
y2 and so forth. Alright. So if we arrange
all these x values into a matrix, and we'll call
it, you know, x. And then we have these other guys. And we'll call this w, like
the coefficents. Obviously w stands for coefficent. And we
want that to sort of equal This vector of
y's. And we basically just need to solve
this equation for the w's. Now, we can't exactly
solve it because it's not going to exactly equal, but
we can solve it in a least squares sense.
So let me just step through the steps for doing that.
Alright, so let's, so here's how we're going to solve for w.
So what we're going to do is premultiply by the transpose of
x. Both sides. I mean really what we wanted to do at
first is if we are solving for Y, we need to
multiply by the inverse of X, but this isn't really going
to be necessarily well behaved. But if we pre mulitplied by
the X transpose then this thing is going to have a nice inverse.
So now we can pre multiply by that inverse.
All right. Now, conveniently because this has a nice
inverse, the inverses cancel each other. [NOISE] We get
that the weights we're looking for can be derived by
taking the x matrix times its own transpose, inverting
that, multiplying by x transpose and then multiplying it
by the y. And that gives us exactly the
coefficients that we need To have done our polynomial regression.
And it just, it just so happens that we have some nice properties in terms
of these x transpose x. Not only is it invertible, but it does the right
thing in terms of minimizing the least squares. It does it as a projection. Now,
we're not going to go through the process by
by which we argue that this is true.
>> Does it have something to do with calculus?
>> It most likely has something to do with calculus. And we'll get
back to calculus later. But in this particular case we can, we're just
using projections and linear algebra. And most importantly the, the whole
process is just we take the, the data we arrange it into
this matrix with whatever sort of powers that we care about.
And then we just compute this quantity and we're good to go.
>> Okay.